el cáncer de tiroides es una enfermedad
que empieza en la glándula tiroides
su glándula tiroides está ubicada debajo
de la laringe o caja de voz Está rodeada
por la tráquea
la tiroides produce dos hormonas
llamadas hormona tiroidea y calcitonina
las cuales son segregadas directamente
en el torrente sanguíneo
en el interior de la glándula tiroides
las células foliculares producen la
hormona tiroidea su cuerpo utiliza la
hormona tiroidea para aumentar su
energía y elevar la temperatura de su
cuerpo cuando es necesario por ejemplo
estos efectos ayudan a reducir el calor
que su cuerpo pierde cuando es expuesto
a climas fríos
las células para foliculares en la
tiroides producen calcitonina
se cree que la calcitonina estimula la
formación de nuevos huesos
si tiene cáncer de tiroides es posible
que tenga uno de los cuatro tipos
dependiendo del tipo de célula tiroidea
en la cual el cáncer ha empezado y la
apariencia de las células cancerígenas
el carcinoma papilar es el cáncer de
tiroides más común y comienza en las
células foliculares el carcinoma
folicular se presenta en uno de cada 10
casos y también empieza en las células
foliculares el carcinoma medular es
menos común y comienzan las células para
foliculares el carcinoma anaplásico de
tiroides es una forma poco común y más
peligrosa de cáncer de tiroides el
cáncer de tiroides como todos los
cánceres presenta un crecimiento
descontrolado de las células debido a un
daño en el material genético del núcleo
celular un tumor se forma a medida que
las células empiezan a acumularse
con el paso del tiempo se forma un bulto
en la tiroides mientras El tumor crece
usted puede sentir El tumor en su cuello
sobre la glándula tiroides usted puede
sentir dolor de cuello o garganta
ronquera y dificultad para tragar a
medida que El tumor crece alrededor de
su tráquea para tratar el cáncer de
tiroides su médico puede recomendar
cirugía seguida de tratamiento con
hormonas tiroideas radioterapia o
quimioterapia
la cirugía es el tratamiento más común
para todos los tipos de cáncer de
tiroides si usted se somete a una
cirugía el médico Generalmente extraerá
su glándula tiroides el médico también
puede extirpar los ganglios linfáticos
cercanos
después de la cirugía su médico puede
recomendar una terapia de hormonas
tiroideas sin su tiroides su cuerpo
tendrá niveles bajos de la hormona
tiroidea Esta condición estimula la
glándula pituitaria en el cerebro para
que libere una hormona estimulante de la
tiroides los niveles elevados de la
hormona estimulante de la tiroides
causan que las células tiroideas
cancerígenas restantes crezcan más
rápido si usted toma la hormona tiroidea
reducirá la cantidad de hormona
estimulante de la tiroides que circula
en su cuerpo la cual impedirá que las
células de cáncer crezcan
si usted tiene cáncer de tiroides
anaplásico y ya ha tenido cirugía su
médico puede recomendar una terapia de
radiación como la terapia de radiación
externa
la radiación daña y mata a las células
tiroideas cancerígenas restantes
después de la cirugía su médico puede
recetarle una píldora que contenga otro
tipo de radioterapia llamada yodo
radioactivo
las células tiroideas cancerígenas
restantes absorben el yodo radioactivo
que las mata
su médico puede recomendar quimioterapia
para el cáncer de tiroides anaplásico
que no responda a la cirugía o a la
radioterapia y que se haya diseminado la
quimioterapia utiliza medicamentos para
detener el avance del cáncer ya sea
destruyendo las células cancerosas o
impidiendo su crecimiento